foreign
[Music]
as a data engineer analyst or data
scientist your main goal is most often
to transform raw data into high quality
insights and ultimately business value
wrangling that data in the form of tasks
like cleaning transforming and mapping
is frequently cited as the most time
consuming part of the process while it's
common to perform wrangling with complex
SQL scripts this approach requires a lot
of Maintenance it's difficult to
operationalize and draws Focus away from
your ultimate goal of uncovering
insights in this video we're going to
show you the Wrangler feature of cloud
data Fusion which is an interactive
visual tool that lets you operationalize
data transformation mapping and
cleansing processes and reduces time to
insights
cloud data Fusion is part of Google
Cloud which means it integrates smoothly
with the rest of our data management
processing and analytics portfolio
Wrangler has an intuitive drag and drop
interface which helps you easily build
transformations to clean and format your
data the tool allows you to test the
effects of your Transformations on a
small subset of the data so that you
gain an understanding of how they will
affect the data set as a whole
once you're happy with their
Transformations recipe you can then run
them as a pipeline within pipeline
Studio to dispatch large parallel
processing jobs on your entire data set
since Wrangler is a visual tool let's
run through an example scenario so that
you can see these features in action
in this demo we'll be cleaning and
transforming data with wrangler's
interactive UI and then creating a
transformation pipeline to ingest the
process data into bigquery
first let's head into the data Fusion UI
the tiles on the home page map to the
cloud data Fusion features such as
pipeline studio and Wrangler
from here we'll head directly to
Wrangler
on the left side you can access
pre-configured connections to your data
in this demo we're using a file located
in a Google Cloud Storage bucket this
CSV file contains a list of
Transportation passengers
if you want to work with multiple data
sources at a given time Wrangler does
provide this option
today though we're focusing on wrangling
our passenger data file
one of the first things you'll see in
the window is the column information
panel the cabin column has only 22.8
percent completion meaning it has some
rows that are missing data
to modify data inside this column or any
column click on the Arrow at the left of
the column name
using a built-in transformation you can
fill all null or empty cells with a
value you provide
after applying this transformation in
the pipeline the cabin column will be
100 complete
then you can use the change data type
function on the passenger ID column to
convert it to integer
Wrangler can also help create data
quality checks you can use a send to
error transformation to report any empty
values present in the age column to the
error collector
as you create your Transformations you
can see them collected in the far right
hand side of the UI
the transformation steps together form a
recipe
a copy of this recipe can be downloaded
so that you can apply it in the future
to other data sets as well
once your recipe is complete you can
utilize the pipelines feature of data
Fusion to apply the transformations to
your entire data set
click create a pipeline and choose batch
pipeline
this opens the studio UI
name your pipeline
then choose sync
this is the destination to which you
want your process data to flow in this
demo the sync is a table in our bigquery
data warehouse
in the properties menu you will provide
the required details to point data
Fusion to a bigquery project
data set ID
and table name
click validate to ensure the properties
are valid
back in the main Studio view you're now
ready to deploy the pipeline
click run to start execution
once the pipeline is finished you can
head over to the bigquery console to
view the destination table
its details and even run queries
we've given you a glimpse into the power
Wrangler has to help you extract more
meaningful insights from your data and
enable faster decision making we know
these are important capabilities as
businesses work to become more data
driven and data informed organizations
to try Wrangler out for yourself check
out the tutorial Linked In the
description below or reach out to your
sales representative if you have any
questions or would like to discuss how
Wrangler can help your data Journey
[Music]